[Music]
thank you for giving on givingtuesday on
behalf of the Carnegie Mellon University
Alumni Association we all like to say
the office of the Annual Giving would
like to say thank you thank you for
giving where your heart is we're
committed to tackling challenging global
problems and educating the world's best
engineers with your help
you'll make it much more possible to do
that thank you thank you thank you so
much for making giving CMU Day a success
every day I get to work with our amazing
students at Carnegie Mellon University
thank you so much for supporting them on
this givingtuesday on behalf of the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences thank you for your
support thank you for your generosity on
behalf of the Mellon College of Science
big and I want to say thank you on
behalf of the tipper School of Business
our students faculty and staff thank you
I wish to thank all of our alumni
students faculty staff parents and
friends who generously contributed to
Carnegie Mellon on giving CMU day our
campus community is stronger when we
come together your gift inspires
Carnegie Mellon's bright and bold future
thank you
[Music]
you